everybody's got their favorite part of
the cycle there are people who love the
wash they love to rinse so the spin or
the drain
i'ma spin guy I love the spin my name is
John Charles and I'm a washer collector
enthusiast laundry day the club that
started around 1987 I think and now we
have like 3,000 members from all over
the world we get together for wash ins
you do laundry till like 4:00 in the
morning you do your margaritas your
laundry together the laundry we watch
the cycles you'll see a lot of us just
stand there watch the whole cycle go
through
oh my god all 3,000 of us come in with a
story like I thought it was the only one
I thought it was the only person in the
world that did this in the collection
I've got 59 machines and I've got 22
hooked up and running down here in the
basement I have a good representation of
everything that was made from 1938 to
today and I take them all apart and I
restore them because I want to know
everything works inside the machine and
then the laundry is for me it's sort of
like the frosting on the cake these
machines represent a lot of ways of
doing things in each decade that changed
that we no longer do and I think it's
something that should be preserved for
other people if we can get them
interested
I just can't go to a cocktail party to
say how does your washer doing and look
at me like I was crazy but I can get
together with these guys let my hair
down it's just so much fun to be able to
have a conversation about it because I
know laundry is a chore for everybody
else but Frost it's it's clay collecting
milk bottles following brown road signs
spotting village water pumps taking
pictures of tombstones appreciating
roundabouts these are dull things to do
aren't they
welcome to the dull men's club I am
Grover click I'm assistant vice
president's club and one of its founders
the Dolans Club is a group that get
together to celebrate the ordinary yeah
began in the 1980s long time ago we
began in in New York City
and later I moved to London and the dull
men's club followed me and has grown
here in England as well it's got members
both in England and America and across
the world the last time we did a roundup
putting all things together it looked
like we had about 5,000 members so here
are the people that do things that some
people think are dull here's Steve I'm a
mobile collector have some 20,000 mill
poles from not just the UK but all over
the world Germany France South Africa
Hong Kong Portugal
I've got Iranian bottles I don't like
milk at all I just don't like it
sorry and we have some women that are
interested in the dull men's club here's
Amanda my quirky hobby is randomly
following ground tourist signs yep you
heard her right I get inspired to turn
off the road whenever I see one I find
it very hard not to I follow Brown signs
around the UK and indeed the whole world
so I've now been to thousands and
thousands we also have a member that
appreciates roundabouts
I'm Kevin and I'm the president of the
UK roundabouts appreciation society also
known as Lord of the Rings that's my
official title I have taken thousands of
pictures of roundabouts even when I'm
abroad on holiday and now a lot of
people would find my hobby quite don't
but it's bright being dull it's sexy
being dull and next as a member that is
just dying to get into a graveyard I'm a
Tomb traveler and I take pictures of
famous graves around the globe probably
over the years four or five hundred on
various parts of the world Kennedy
Martin Luther King Bruce Lee and Brandon
Lee Elvis Presley Ludwig van Beethoven
and Charlie Chaplin well I don't feel
that I'm a doorman that people have said
that but I prefer to think that I've got
a rounded I'll be an interest it takes
my mind away from work and we have dick
through spotting village water pumps and
they all came about to accident ten
years ago somebody pointed out a tiny
little pump by the side of the road and
almost every village we went to I'd say
there's a pump we doesn't slam the
brakes on and jump out and take a
picture of the pump it's okay to be dull
there are a lot of studies being done
now that boredom has got benefits we're
not so interested in the glitz and glam
we're quite happy with simple things in
life
the very first time I left the ground in
a general plane I knew it was over but
my life was done it's all gonna be about
two aeroplanes and it was not just
because I was in the air but I was
depending upon myself so my safety was
in my own hands it was one of the most
exhilarating sensations that I've ever
received in my life my name is George
Jacob and I'm known as gyro Jake that I
build gyroplanes from scratch
what a gyroplane is basically a hybrid
airplane helicopter but it's neither of
the two how many gyroplanes I would say
I'd built close to 20 I lost count
around 13 a few years back I imagined
what I want and what components should
fit together
then I machine out and weld up the parts
that are necessary to get the job
completed well sometimes you can take
two months sometimes it could take a
year there's times I look at it and I go
man I did that and it works and I want
to fly it when I first started it was a
pretty small clinic in Florida and so
we'd get together on the weekends today
the gyro community is probably increased
by a hundredfold especially with the new
revolution of the factory built gyros to
do-it-yourself builders or kind of like
the dinosaurs they're on their way to
being extinct there aren't many people
that spend most of the free time
building a gyroplane one after the other
after the other
there's no incentive like money that
compels me to do this it's just because
this is my pleasure this is my joy this
is my passion
you
football is the most popular sport in
Sierra Leone in the city of Freetown
there is one very special team meet the
Flying Stars my name nawa mela pia had a
play for sunroof lynnster and achievable
club exactly
mohammad grew up playing football but
when he was only 10 years old he stepped
on a landmine and had to have his right
leg amputated and unfortunately mohammad
isn't alone the saloon flames the
amputee football team the war affected
amplitude bladder so so did every member
of the Flying Stars has lost limbs as a
result of the violence that occurred
during the civil war in Sierra Leone but
the players don't let their injuries
stop them from getting into the game
Goldie Boudreau then coach is ready to
jump really rough then the blue to one
foot one leg vitally mean the coach for
the flying star amputee football club
president Lina Latoya taxi Plaza now
where value within Fulton we go to 12
weeks ago
well Galloway co-worker country welcome
they walk in put gas on hungry blue
level they do Ln short shorts to Ornish
desert and Schottky clunky penalty
shoot-out until at 70 normal act out the
ability to well
not only is it a competitive sport it is
helping them cope with their injuries
and overcome the stigma that's
associated with the disabled what is
this discrimination artists - country
offensive we need for do some ceramic
forget all problem
in what better way than football college
football especially the unbelievable
Nigerian life and on my calendar on our
streets Abu Bakr the lure of college
that's not only member on the PRM
moi
I think a lot of people look at hula as
just women dancing but um we love it man
hula is a story to tell the story the
way the ancient hawaiians did you really
need to put yourself in that dance you
need to live like them you need to chant
like them
you need to train like them basically
you need to become them
you know even I know how low is the hula
school we perform all over the world in
ancient times
warriors are actually recruited from the
hollow the chief would come to look from
the ranks of the advanced male dancers
Warriors were selected the philosophy of
our Hollow is to kind of replicate that
for male Pula were basically telling
warrior stories and to dance like a
warrior
you need a train like a warrior we train
in a private piece of land on the west
side of Oahu using only what ancient
hawaiians head
whether it's rocks the sand the ocean
when we come to practice we expect to
die
it's strenuous on the legs but it's also
to train your mind I tell myself and the
rest of the boys if I fall it's because
my body just gave up
one of the hardest workouts we do would
be climbing the coconut tree
sometimes you reach the top and your
legs are shaking because you know you're
holding your weight and to look down
knowing that nothing's holding you you
got to kind of have this warrior mindset
as like you know that this is what I
want you know I'm gonna get this
you know when these gentlemen come to
hula they're like a ball of clay that's
cool more I look at it as my
responsibility to shape them into better
individuals better fathers better sons
better brothers our goal is that when
these men are done dancing that they
leave here better people
what who led this for me culturally it
still takes me back to Taha Hawaii used
to be
people sometimes are losing that Aloha
for each other that love for each other
and hula just gives you that reality
check man I'm dancing until my kneecaps
fall off and even after that I'm gonna
do whatever I can for the hollow
you know we have this Brotherhood where
we take care of each other we help push
each other it's my passion and I look
forward to seeing where hula takes me in
life